octa log in bremen kicking off a tour to
promote their new album the band from
Greece I'm combines retro sounds with
modern indie rock gonna be an ED now but
when we work out ideas in the rehearsal
room we see whether we get that octo log
feel or not where does get technician
when you got invest finna joggle ishtam
regardless of the genre or style we're
experimenting with it always sounds like
us in the end things in video we don't
know please they certainly take their
time with their music some of their
tracks go on for more than 20 minutes
the buckets I love those long guitar
solos that was really otherworldly
Mangano's I loved it fantastic they're a
great band yes it's great if they take
time to play songs that are longer than
three minutes
on the title track diamonds and despair
psychedelic rock from the 1960s meets
sense sounds from the 80s and
contemporary electro beats
singer and bass player Ben O'Hare set up
the band in 2007 with his brother Robert
who's the drummer
essentially super quittin it's also have
a brother who makes music to Zika who's
a friend and a colleague all in one item
is this yeah um yeah we're not like
Oasis yeah thnkx 50 in the am kind of
have you thrown your guitars at each
other yet I know we have not any bites
on stage although we have come close
they spend a lot of time at their
parents home in darmstadt in central
Germany the pool has featured in their
videos more than once and they also
rehearse inside the house
to drive
the handguns humid lighten up to spend a
lot of time in our hometown where our
practice room is and where some of us
still live or used to live pizzas on my
owls and we go out partying here and
hang out with our families and all of
that is part of the octa lifestyle
hidden files a little tighter fun didn't
akhtar lifestyle
octa toured Europe in the US with their
first two albums to critical acclaim the
new album took 18 months to make this
time the guys wanted to move away from
the retro sound in the process becoming
increasingly experimental these my visor
the time was more about the synthesizer
and key sounds which we didn't have
before before I only hadn't seemed leave
it be soon we really read through a very
loving painstaking fiddly process which
you can tell from the album but some
onion
dr. Lu combining sounds from yesteryear
and now they're probably the band of
tomorrow
you